[Applaudissements]
euh
[Musique]
quand je repense à ce jour-là, de petits
détails me restent à l'esprit.
cruauté aveugle
peut-être que nous n'aurions pas dû être surpris
sommes-nous vraiment si différents il y a du mal à l'
intérieur de nous
tous merci  du
bout des doigts
je ne peux jamais décider à quoi jouer la
paralysie de choix je l'ai quand je vais à
l'hypermarché
il y a 100 options différentes je veux juste du
dentifrice
avez-vous vu ceci
quelle est la source
ross128
pouvez-vous vérifier la fréquence
153,26 gigahertz
si élevée qui peut être juste
c'est ce qu'il dit pouvez-vous solidifier le
signal
[Music] [Music]
cela pourrait être un satellite
je vérifierai avec l'utilisateur
aucun satellite enregistré dans ce passe-bande
y a-t-il un pulsar là-bas
non il n'y a pas de pulsar à ces
coordonnées
et t  la fréquence est trop élevée
qu'est-ce que le signal que le récepteur a
capté l'année dernière
vous savez celui de ross 128b
c'est le même ouais mais c'est beaucoup
plus fort
alors que disons-nous
qu'est-ce qu'il n'y a pas de
phénomène naturel qui peut produire un signal comme
cette
[musique]
pas à cette fréquence
où la mettriez-vous sur l'échelle de rio
je ne sais pas
six euh peut-être sept
[musique
] sortir plus tard nous avons besoin de quelqu'un d'autre pour la
vérifier
et contacter alma leur demander de jeter un œil
à  ça
[Musique]
johannes désolé
chut d'
accord
et oma confirme le signal
qu'ils obtiennent les mêmes lectures
qu'ils retournent en
phase à nouveau êtes-vous vraiment sûr que cela
peut être possible
j'ai déjà vérifié c'est réel et
si nous nous trompons et  avoir l'air ridicule
nous n'avons pas tort
passer l'appel
commencer t  mauvaise nuit je
rencontre des amis d'accord prenons une
banane
manger une banane est ta réponse à
tout a l'
air douloureux tu l'as mangé n'est ce pas
c'est ton bras tu vas le dire à papa
tes amis
pourquoi es-tu habillé pour l'école j'ai dit j'ai
appelé la terre
hé mon pote comment tu vas ouais sa mère d'
accord
[Musique]
ouais ouais non non je ne peux pas lui parler maintenant
parce que
je vérifie juste mais euh dis-lui que je vais
l'appeler plus tard d'accord d'accord d'
accord ouais bravo mon pote d'accord
dis-lui bonjour de ma part au revoir l'
augmentation de l'amplitude du
courant de stimulation entraîne l'
hyperactivation du
cortex somatosensoriel et
prémoteur primaire c'est la preuve directe qu'un courant induit
contribue le plus
à corticospinal  l'excitation de la voie,
donc augmenter l'
amplitude de stimulation
augmenterait la quantité de neurones qui se
déclenchent et entraînerait une réponse plus importante
, comme nous venons de le voir,
excusez-moi, je vous
ennuie, hmm, peut-être devrions-nous déclencher quelques neurones
dans votre brai  n juste pour faire couler le jus,
nous pouvons donner un sens à cela grâce à notre
ciblage de diverses structures neuronales
par deux demi-segments,
le signal a été détectable pendant exactement 23
heures et 56 minutes d'
un côté du jour réel une rotation complète
de la
terre y a-t-il une signification dans  que nous
ne savons pas que
vous faites partie de l'initiative methi
vous avez envoyé des messages dans l'espace
nous envoyons de la musique l'idée est que la musique
agirait comme un langage universel
mais s'ils n'ont pas d'oreilles ils ne
pourront pas  l'entendre donc nous avons codé le
message entier dans un système binaire
de deux fréquences alternatives pulsées
125 fois par seconde
pourrait-il s'agir d'une réponse si c'est
dans une langue que nous ne comprenons pas
les ondes électromagnétiques ont été
transmises sur une grande distance avec
pratiquement aucun  atténuation
qu'est-ce que cela signifie cela signifie que
la source d'alimentation qui a généré le signal
est supérieure à ce que nous pouvons même
concevoir cela signifie-t-il qu'ils sont une menace
il n'y a aucune preuve suggérant que tha
Il serait sûrement tout aussi faux de
supposer qu'ils ne sont pas une menace
Dr Duran, que savons-nous
il y a deux ans, nous avons découvert une exoplanète en
orbite autour de Ross
128. La planète est une zone habitable et elle
peut peut-être supporter la vie,
mais c'est tout ce que nous  savoir
pourquoi détectons-nous ce signal maintenant
nous ne pouvons pas dire avec certitude peut-être qu'ils
nous cherchaient
merci peut-être nous croyez-vous oui
étranger
libre
à environ 2300 heures temps universel
dr catherine durand de l'institut la
radioastronomie
millimétrique a détecté un
signal puissant  originaire d'une zone proche de
l'étoile
ross 128. toutes les preuves suggèrent que
ce signal
est révélateur d'
une vie extraterrestre intelligente
j'espère que cette découverte est quelque chose qui
unira
la race humaine peut-être verrons-nous maintenant
que
nous nous ressemblons beaucoup plus que nous ne le sommes
[Musique]
différent
qu'est-ce que c'est
[Musique]
par ici
euh
[Musique]
comment ça s'est passé à Bruxelles c'était bon
hé papa oh salut
tu repars je  Je vais
dormir dans le bureau pendant que ça se passe
alors qu'est-ce qu'ils ne nous disent pas si nous étions
inquiets il n'y a rien à dire
ils ont détecté un signal
non quand le gouvernement vous dit de ne pas
paniquer c'est à ce moment que vous devez acheter un fusil
et dirigez-vous vers les collines
tu te tirerais une balle dans le pied tu
serais allongé là en espérant que le
gouvernement pervers vienne et te sauve
tu veux que j'ouvre ça oh je peux ouvrir une
bouteille de vin
as-tu parlé à ta mère elle va bien
je  es-tu demain soir, jack a dit
qu'il avait laissé tomber
le reste de mes affaires que suis-je
censé lui dire,
essayez une conversation polie, je suis sûr
que vous comprendrez, vous ne voulez pas que
j'en colle un sans lui  parce qu'il
t'a largué
tu es censé me faire me sentir mieux
je t'appellerai d'accord
devrait sortir pour le lancement du produit je
suppose qu'il est fou
ouais c'est difficile tu sais pour moi d'
être loin de chez moi trop longtemps
oh je pensais  tu as dit que ta fille
ramassait beaucoup mieux maintenant
ouais c'est elle  est alors venu aujourd'hui les gars
ça va être amusant
devrais-je prendre une autre bouteille maintenant tu sais
ce qu'il est tard
mais tu pourrais m'inviter dans ta
chambre
oh peut-être que c'est une mauvaise idée est-
ce que tu nous manques
le
oh
euh d'
accord
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il se passe quelque chose
m'étranger
quoi
[Musique]
atmosphère
une attaque
qu'est-ce qui se passe qu'est-ce que c'est
ne devrions-nous pas faire quelque chose faire qu'est-
ce que c'est
bordel emily qu'est-ce que tu fais tu peux le sentir
pénétrer à l'intérieur
les attaques de la nuit dernière ont envoyé des tremblements effrayants à
travers le monde
24 heures sur 24 pour sauver des rapports
suggèrent plus de 2
500 objets montrent que les sites de l'accident se
sont réunis
dernières nouvelles le gouvernement a
répondu
en déclarant l'état d'urgence les
écoles ont été fermées et tous
les avions civils sont  jusqu'à
nouvel ordre,
nous recevons des rapports d'écriture à
londres, manchester et birmingham,
il y a une grave congestion sur toutes les routes en
dehors des grandes villes, cela ne
fera qu'empirer
oh nous devons obtenir  le message que les gens
devraient rester chez eux c'est l'
endroit le plus sûr pour eux
je m'y mettrai votre famille est là
c'est juste une précaution jusqu'à ce que les choses se calment
tenez-moi au courant
des poissons étrangers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] les
niveaux sont normaux  test négatif pour
les interférences chimiques et biologiques
[Applaudissements]
je dis qu'il est partiellement enfoui dans le
sol
c'est un objet métallique sphérique non poreux les
équipes alpha entrent
[Applaudissements]
je répète les niveaux de radioactivité normaux
négatifs agents biologiques chimiques
fort champ électromagnétique
objet métallique
sphérique non poreux  partiellement intégré
um
sofia
ugh
euh les
gens sortent de londres alors
peut-être que je devrais aller dans ma terre jusqu'à ce que tu
saches ce qui se passe
ouais tu devrais aller le euh le
tunnel sous la Manche est toujours ouvert donc je vais
voir si je peux prendre un train
et je vais rencontrer ton père
sarah j'ai juste besoin d'être prudent
je voulais juste vérifier et voir que
tu vas bien
ces choses la nuit dernière dieu c'est fou
helen bill  un des voisins t'a vu
traîner dans l'appartement la nuit dernière bon
sang je passais juste par là était-ce cette
vieille chienne folle avec ce chien de merde
elle ne m'a jamais aimé tu sais que c'est son chien
qui chie dans le couloir
ce n'est pas approprié pour toi de juste
présentez-vous ici
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
va se passer avec nous
je suis
désolé encore une fois
je vais lui parler il est juste inquiet que
ce n'est pas son travail de s'inquiéter pour vous
la découverte la plus importante jusqu'à présent
a été que les astrophysiciens  au brésil
qui ont été les premiers à observer
une activité électromagnétique concentrée
dans leur processus local plusieurs sources
ont maintenant confirmé l'
étranger
mes parents veulent absolument que je sois avec
eux
alors mais je resterai si vous le voulez
bien sûr mais
vous devriez y aller d'
accord au revoir
expert  l'analyse indique que les sondes
émettent un champ électromagnétique
bien que l'on comprenne peu son
objectif, les scientifiques du monde entier sont
pris dans un débat fervent quant aux
implications,
mais aucune conclusion  Des réponses sives ont été
trouvées jusqu'à présent, il y a encore des
spéculations répandues quant à la cause de l'
abandon des coupures de courant.
Communications mobiles.
à vous plus tard
non les gars écoutez-moi alors les
champs électromagnétiques que ces sondes
émettent
je pense qu'ils sont conçus pour interférer avec
notre fonctionnement neuronal ils sont identiques
aux impulsions que nous utilisons pour simuler les neurones
dans le cerveau
c'est exactement la même fréquence et
amplitude tout  c'est presque comme
s'ils comprenaient notre neurologie,
comment est-ce même possible, je ne sais pas,
mais à mesure que le pouls devient plus fort, cela
va déclencher de plus en plus de neurones,
cela provoquera des
crises et notre corps s'arrêtera
complètement, êtes-vous sûr
que sûr  comme il se peut que les gens aient besoin de se rendre dans un
endroit complètement enfermé dans du métal ou dans
un sous-sol profond,
vous devez amener le gouvernement à
émettre un avertissement d'
accord, je vais euh je  'll parler au ministre
[Musique]
merde,
il dit que nous allons commencer à nous adapter que nos
corps vont complètement s'arrêter oui nos
scientifiques disent la même chose
qu'ils ont fait des tests à portland
vous saviez
alors nous devons émettre un  alerte nous ne pouvons pas
émettre d'avertissement jusqu'à ce que nous soyons sûrs que nous
ne pouvons pas risquer une panique de masse et
s'il est trop tard [ __ ] la
décision a été prise d'accord
nous attendons
oui allez-y d'accord
merci
[Musique]
nous retournons les gens
et quoi  est-ce que nous faisons peut-être devrions-nous simplement
rentrer à la maison
je pensais que tu avais dit que ce n'était pas sûr là-bas
je ne suis pas sûr que nous ayons beaucoup de choix
je pense que c'est mon calme plus tard nous pouvons
réessayer
papa texte lui faire savoir que nous y allons  à la maison d'
accord
où est-ce que
tu peux sentir quelque chose qu'est-ce
qu'il y a ce son je l'ai entendu hier soir
peux-tu l'entendre non
c'est tellement bizarre
merci
excusez-moi excusez-moi est-ce qu'il y a
un autre itinéraire que nous pourrions prendre ou d'
accord d'
accord c'est tout ce que j'ai  moi là
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'est-ce que c'est
pas
ils disent là'  ça va être une
attaque c'est le fil twitter du gouvernement
ils disent aux gens de trouver un abri
pour entrer dans la clandestinité
que devrions-nous faire je ne sais pas maman je
ne sais pas
pourquoi ils tirent sur les gens
je suis sûr qu'ils sont  juste tirer en l'
air qui aura un sens
ta voix change quand tu mens
que tu ne comprends pas
il y a une attaque non non tu dois te
calmer ça se passe
maman maman qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire
maman fais quelque chose maman
ralentis
je vais vite
sortir
qu'est ce que tu fais là tu dois venir
avec moi en ce moment viens avec moi en ce moment
tu vas mourir
dans l'ascenseur ça va nous protéger contre
le champ électromagnétique
as tu vu la corée ouais je sais je
ne suis pas monté dans l'ascenseur maintenant
nous devons d'abord trouver chris nous  Je n'ai pas le
temps
[Applaudissements]
bonjour sofia
étranger
oh
uh
[Musique]
um
toi